et monopolise et dans le plateau regarde
gentil n'es-tu pas juste mais toutes ces
armes changent tout le temps
qu'ils ont tiré sur Ryan et Manuel si tu veux mon
amitié si tu veux mon soutien ne
divise pas les votes je n'ai pas besoin du  vision
Je me bats en ce moment contre une charte
parce qu'ils divisent les gens et
c'est de la diversion parce qu'ils pensent que
nous pouvons mangue ils n'enregistrent pas et
au Plateau Rafael je pensais que tu étais tombé amoureux de
toutes ces façons qui changent tout
le temps
ils ont tiré sur Ryan et bien d'autres si vous voulez
mon amitié si vous voulez mon soutien
ne divisez pas les votes Je n'ai pas besoin de la
vision Je me bats en ce moment contre une
charte parce qu'ils divisent les
gens et c'est une diversion parce qu'ils
pense que nous pouvons mangue ne pas enregistrer à
nouveau